Fortuna Düsseldorf gewinnt auch unter Neu-Coach Markus Anfang nicht, führt weiter mit Negativ-Trend und zwei Vereine können erst mal aufatmen. Wir sprechen mit Lisa Höfer und Tobias Rieger über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer und los geht's.
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Krossi zu Kurzabwehr, lang genug für Gili Landgraf.
Wagner, Martin Wagner. Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kort aus dem Bewühl.
Alexander Schur!
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja, willkommen zurück zur Ligatour, zur 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Mein Name ist Eva-Lotta Bohle. Ihr könnt mich sonst im 11 Freunde am Abend Podcast hören oder generell im Rasenfunk-Universum. Schön, dass ihr wieder dabei seid als Zuhörende. Und wenn ich schon von wieder dabei sein spreche, dann darf ich als erstes Lisa Höfer begrüßen, die am Anfang der Saison schon mal da war. Hallo Lisa.
Ja, also ich fange trotzdem einmal ganz kurz bei Marius Wöhl an. Tobi, du wirst es mir verzeihen. Erstens einfach absolut Big Brain Move, als gefeiert halb Pokalheld aus der letzten Saison in der ersten Runde auszuscheiden und dann doch in der zweiten Runde zu stehen, weil man danach erst wechselt. Es ist ein Big Brain Move, sage ich wie es ist. Aber ja, ich glaube da muss man sagen, der Junge muss noch so ein bisschen reinfinden, sowohl in die 2. Liga als auch diesen Hype, der um seine Person natürlich entstanden ist, mit seiner Rückkehr, dem gerecht zu werden. Ich fand jetzt zum Beispiel, aber das Spiel gegen Elversberg zeigt wieder, warum man ihn eben auch zurückgeholt hat, wenn er auch in der richtigen Position spielt. Dann zu Munchimumulu, das ist so wirklich ein Spieler, wo ich dachte, warum holt man den jetzt zurück? Hat das mehr so auch Nostalgie-Vibes und hey, und Kniart wollte schon den ganzen Zeit? Und war das vielleicht von Mutzel auch nochmal so ein kleiner, ich sag mal, also nicht, Seitenhieb auf Markus Mann, der ja groß getönt hat im Sommer, es werden keine Spieler von Hannover nach Bielefeld wechseln? So, ob das vielleicht auch noch, aber dazu muss man einfach sagen, ich glaube, Mumulu ist unser bester Scorer, weil der einfach unfassbar viel Tempo mit reinbringt, zusammen mit Benjamin Boacsi, der als nicht gelernter Rechtsverteidiger, zum Teil einen besseren Rechtsverteidiger machte als Chris Lallard, sorry dafür, Chris, der da super arbeitet, ne? Und also das einzige Problem ist, glaube ich, noch, der kann bisher noch nicht mehr als 65 Minuten, das ist halt so ein bisschen schade, wenn du deinen mitspielstärksten Spieler halt immer nach so 60 Minuten rausnehmen musst und dann halt wirklich schon, ich sag mal in Anführungszeichen, Leistungsabfall auf der Seite siehst oder den taktisch umstellen musst, aber per se Mumulu Super, das erinnere ich mir an Basé. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich der Spieler, wo man echt wirklich sagt, hätte der halt nicht diese vielen Verletzungen gehabt. Erstens hätte Bielefeld ihn niemals in der dritten Liga zu sich holen können, das ist sowieso klar. Und zweitens wird er auch lange nicht mehr hier spielen. Ich glaube, da sind wir uns alle einig. Ich freue mich für ihn, dass er wieder zurück ist. Er hatte ja alleine durch das Pokalspiel, das Pokalfinale, glaube ich, durchaus so ein bisschen was zu knabbern. Wenn ihr es nicht gesehen habt, da kam so ein Schostenfuss. Und damit Gummo an der Stelle. Also, das hat er, glaube ich, hat ihn selber relativ lange noch beschäftigt, was hätte werden können. Aber da sieht man eben auch, der ist vielleicht nicht mehr der Schnellste, aber er bringt durchaus gute Qualität mit rein. Das war jetzt eine sehr lange Antwort auf deine Frage. Es tut mir leid, aber ich würde per se sagen, Hannover macht sich gut.
Er war mal so unfassbar schnell als der. Wahnsinn. Aber halt immer kaputt, immer verletzt. Das war wirklich... Oh Mann, dann gewechselt er nach Augsburg und es wurde nicht besser. Der tut mir nicht wirklich jedes Mal leid, wenn ich an den denke. Von daher freue ich mich sehr, dass es ihm bei euch einigermaßen gut geht.
Lisa, du wolltest gerne was noch ergänzen.
Ich frage jetzt nicht nach den Ex-Nürnbergern. Shoutout Tim Handwerker. Vermisse ich sehr, aber sehe ich, dass er sich sehr, sehr gut macht. Ich muss tatsächlich sagen, ich fand es ganz spannend, weil Tobi gerade auch noch mal so ein bisschen auf PK war. Und was ist denn so ein bisschen jetzt auch der Vibe gerade gewesen. Ich muss ja echt sagen, ich konnte total gut nachempfinden. Und das habe ich auch echt oft gelesen jetzt. Man holt irgendwie das Pokalgesicht raus. Und es ist wieder Pokalmentalität in Bielefeld, dass das immer noch was ist, was glaube ich so von außen dann auch noch mal anders irgendwie beflügelt. Dass das zumindest in meiner Bubble an Bielefeld-Fans immer noch was ist. Selbst wenn es schlecht läuft, man erinnert sich irgendwie noch an diesen schönen, schönen Erfolg. Man geht jetzt, also alle, die ich kenne, haben jetzt auch schon wieder Bock aufs Pokalspiel, auch wenn es hart wird gegen Union. Da interessiert mich gleich dein Tipp, auch wenn du sagst, du tippst keine Liga-Megapher. Aber da musst du uns gleich noch abholen. Und ich finde, das hat man tatsächlich in dem Spiel auch irgendwie gesehen. Also irgendwie kompakt verteidigt, diszipliniert gespielt, Leidenschaft war irgendwie dabei. Umschaltmomente hatte glaube ich Tobi auch schon erwähnt. Gerade so diese Mentalität, diese Tugenden, das ist es dann halt oft auch. Gerade wenn du aus so einer Negativ-Serie kommst oder wenn es vielleicht auch schon irgendwie ein bisschen Unruhe gibt an der einen oder anderen Stelle. Und da immer dieses Wort so Pokal-Gesicht, Pokal-Mentalität, das freut mich irgendwie sehr. Und das ist so ein bisschen was, wo ich auch Bielefeld und auch so die Bielefelder Bubble immer ein bisschen beneide, weil ich das Gefühl habe, das wünscht sich irgendwie jeder Club so ein bisschen für sein Team. Und ich gönne das und gucke aber gleichzeitig auch so ein bisschen neidisch hin und bin sehr, sehr gespannt jetzt auf den Mittwoch, wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe, wenn Bielefeld gegen Union ran muss. Da musst du den Tipp noch geben. Also da würde ich jetzt nicht raus.
Ich dachte mir das schon. Ich freue mich sehr.
Ich habe Elbersberg als Absteiger getippt. Ja, da bist du ja nicht die Einzige.
Da bist du ja nicht die Einzige. Ich glaube, also du hast mehrere Sachen gesagt. Ich fand es so interessant, dass du gesagt hast, die Pokalmentalität, wie die raus soll. Ich würde tatsächlich noch was anderes sagen. Und das ist die Gewissheit, dass man aus Krisen sich rausarbeiten kann. Weil, ich habe das schon an anderer Stelle gesagt, mir geht manchmal unter, dass Bielefeld keinen linearen Verlauf in der letzten Saison hatte. Da ging es damals schon zwischendurch mal richtig tief, gerade zum Jahresstart. Aber diese Mannschaft, die eben erstens zum größten Teil aus der Mannschaft besteht, die damals gegen den Klassen erhalt, also wirklich mit dem Rücken zur Wand ging, die Existenz stand. Das muss man einfach so klar sagen. Wer Bielefeld in die Regionalliga abgestiegen, das wäre nicht schön geworden. Und da ist eben auch ein guter Kern noch vorhanden an den Spielern. Und sie haben letztes Jahr auch keine einfache Saison gehabt. Und ich glaube, die können jetzt aber sagen, Leute, wir standen wie im Soll, wir hatten schon mal unsere 10 Punkte. Wir sind damit nicht unter den Strich gerutscht. Ich glaube, das war einfach wichtig. Und gleichzeitig konnte man sagen, wir sind immer noch Aussteiger. Für uns ist das eine ganz andere Situation, als Aussteiger mal zu sagen, wir haben eine schwäche Phase, als Absteiger, als Verein, der nach einem Jahr 3. Liga mal raus wollte. Und das einzige Problem war, dass man, du hast eben von Tugenden gesprochen und Bielefelds Tugenden in den letzten anderthalb Jahren waren. Ich fand es so witzig, dass Tobi es eben angesprochen hat. Nach einer Führung hat Bielefeld anderthalb Jahre lang nicht verloren. Also ich habe irgendwann mal eine Statistik aufgeschrieben, wie viele Führungen man hatte. Das war, da hatte man das, das letzte Mal war, glaube ich im Februar 2024 das Derby gegen Preußen Münster, wo man geführt hatte und das verloren hatte. Und danach hat man nicht einmal ein Spiel noch hinten raus verloren nach Führung. Und jetzt eben zweimal diese Spiele gehabt zu haben, einmal gegen Hannover, obwohl man da ja fast auch im Rückstand gewesen wäre, hätte Tobi Rieger nicht entschieden, den dümmsten Elfmeter aller der Geschichte zu schießen. Das muss man ja an der Stelle wirklich noch mal sagen.
Noch dümmer war der in Cottbus, also den hat der auch.
True, true. Jaja, richtig, richtig. Also gut, da wäre man da ja endlich auch schon früher in Rückstand geraten, glaube ich. Und dann gab es da ja auch noch das, bzw. da gab es auch dieses komische Abseitstor, wo es erst nicht klar war, ob Hannspiel abseits war, Ball im Tor. Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau. Auf jeden Fall so. Und da war aber das erste Spiel, was man nach Führung hergegeben hat. Und dann gab es ja dieses absolute Freak-Spiel gegen Paderborn, wo man 2-1 geführt hat und dann innerhalb von 15 Minuten nach der Pause drei Gegentore bekommen hat und dann eben 4 zu 3 verloren hat. Aber man muss eben sagen, diese Mannschaft gibt halt nie auf. Also diese Lauf, diese intensiven Läufe, diese guten Fitnesswerte kommen eben auch davon, dass diese Mannschaft bis zur letzten Minute rennt. Ob das beim 3-1 gegen Fürth so war, ob das beim 2-1 gegen Schalke oder den Niederlagen war. Und ich glaube, das ist was, das kann man dieser Mannschaft nicht vorwerfen, dass sie eben nicht bis zur letzten Minute kämpft. Und das ist was, wo ganz viele Bielefeld-Fans auch deshalb relativ entspannt gewesen sind. Also warum, ich glaube, noch nie so entspannt auf die Niederlagen in Folge geguckt wurde, weil man einfach gesagt hat, naja, wir wissen, diese Mannschaft kann das schaffen und diese Mannschaft hat das schon geschafft. Und im Vergleich zu vor drei Jahren, wo man erstens zu dem Zeitpunkt mit weniger Punkten da stand und zweitens eine ganz, ganz andere Mannschaftsgebilde hatte damals, können das, glaube ich, viele Bielefeld-Fans auch richtig einordnen. Aber es war halt trotzdem einfach so, du hast das angesprochen, diese Defensive, die war halt, was so ein Prunkspruch war, die stand halt unter Beschuss und da war es schon gut. Und dazu muss man sagen, also ein maximgroßer Spiel, jetzt quasi Sechser, einfach da muss man so ein bisschen auf Kaderplanung gehen, hat man da eventuell Fehler gemacht. Man hat irgendwie eigentlich drei Innenverteidiger zur Verfügung, das ist ein bisschen wenig auf langen Gesicht gesehen, weil Jonathan Norby, den man eben auch noch geholt hat, eher so für die neu gegründete U21 spielt. Und man hat aber einen viel größeren Ausfall und das ist Stefano Russo, der sich ja im Spiel gegen Hannover verletzt hat. Und der ist das Bindeglied dieser Mannschaft. Nehmt Mal Corbus, ist das der Spieler, wo ich bis heute sage, es ist unfassbar wichtig, dass die beiden so schnell in der 2. Liga angekommen sind. Und da sage ich auch bis heute, mein Respekt. Ich glaube, Mal Corbus läuft jedes Spiel über 13 km. Ich würde mich einfach weigern, aber gut, deshalb mache ich auch keinen Profisport. Also das noch, glaube ich, zusammengesammt. Joel Felix war verletzt, Tim Handwerker verletzt, Noah Sarangin-Bazé. Mit Ul Drikes hast du einen Stürmer, der hoffentlich jetzt vielleicht zum Ende des Jahres nochmal kurz wiederkommt, aber sonst eben auch nochmal eine Option für vorne hast. Vielleicht findet Marvin Melem auch irgendwann seine Rolle in diesem Kader. Also ich würde sagen, und das habe ich, glaube ich, schon Anfang der Saison gesagt, in diesem Kader ist Potenzial nach oben. Und ich sage das immer wieder gerne, wenn ein Trainer gezeigt hat, dass er das aus Spielern rausholen kann, dann ist das mitgeklärt. So, jetzt habe ich doch ein Monologe gehalten, es tut mir leid.
Jetzt fehlt nur noch dein Tipp.
Danke.
Hast du auch gemerkt, Tobi?
Ja, so. Das Ding ist, ich mache mir das jetzt einfach, weil Grüße gehen raus an die Kolleginnen vom RWB, mit denen habe ich heute morgen gesprochen vor dem Pokalspiel. Und da musste ich auch tippen, die haben einen Nein nicht gelten lassen. Und ich habe einfach gesagt, 1-0 Bielefeld. Wie ist mir vollkommen egal, 1-0 Bielefeld, gerne in 90 Minuten. 20, 45 Spiele gehören abgeschafft im Winter. Es ist jetzt seit ungefähr acht Stunden dunkel. Ich möchte da einfach schnell wieder raus. Und in Berlin braucht man ja auch so ein bisschen, bis man da wieder aus den Stadien raus ist.
Ich glaube, da rätst du offene Türen ein. Ich werde am Mittwoch bei der Sportshow arbeiten. Und da ist das die gleiche Devise, wenn der Klub nicht spielt. Am besten nach 90 Minuten durch. Wer gewinnt, na ja, schauen wir mal. Aber 1-0, ich bin froh, dass du dich zum Tipp hast überzeugen lassen.
Ja, ja.
Ihr seid schuld, ne? Also wir wissen alle, der RBB und ihr beide seid schuld. Wenn das nicht klappt, weil ihr habt mich gezwungen. Und das finde ich nicht nett.
Aber der RBB war schon vor uns. Also guck mal, wir haben es jetzt nur noch mal so ausgenutzt. Ich wusste es nicht, aber...
So oder so. Viel wichtiger wird danach das Auswahlspiel in Darmstadt und zu Hause gegen Karlsruhe. Und da sage ich ja einfach mal ganz uneigennützlich, ich hoffe, wir sehen da mehr von dem Gesicht gegen Elbersberg als von dem Gesicht gegen Schalke Hannover. Und Paderborn, das ist meine Meinung dazu, aber ich habe da vollstes Vertrauen. Dann springen wir zu unserem letzten Team. Und ich sage das hier nochmal, es mag Leute vielleicht ein wenig komisch vorkommen, wenn sie den Titel dieser Sendung gelesen haben und dachten, warum zum Henga kommt Hannover 96 hier drin vor. Man steht nämlich schließlich auf Platz 4, hat 20 Punkte, 18 zu 13 Tore, 6 Siege, 2 Unentschieden, 2 Niederlagen. In der Formtabelle steht man auf Platz 6. Dazu muss ich sagen, vor diesem Spieltag stand man da ein bisschen niedriger da. Und das war so ein bisschen der Grund, warum wir uns angeguckt haben, was ist eigentlich nach der Niederlage gegen Hertha so passiert. Da gab es so eine leichte Schwächephase. Also man hatte jetzt zuletzt eine 0-3, also vor dem Derbysieg 0-3 gegen Schalke, Unentschieden gegen Fürth, zwar ein Sieg gegen Nürnberg, aber auch ein Unentschieden gegen Dresden. Also da gab es so eine Schwächephase. Aber, Tobi, bevor wir gleich über das Derby sprechen, würdest du das als leichte Schwächephase bezeichnen oder würdest du einfach sagen, das hat was mit dem Grundlevel der Liga zu tun?
Könnte man darauf schieben. Ich fand, es war eine Schwächephase. Ich fand, es war auch keine wirklich coole Zeit, weil man ist ja wirklich gestartet wie verrückt, mit vier Spielen, vier Siegen. Wir hatten zwischendurch vier Punkte Vorsprung auf Platz zwei. Ganz, ganz absurdes Gefühl nach vier Spieltagen. Und dann, du hast es angesprochen, diese beiden Heimspiele, es war zu Hause gegen Hertha, es war zu Hause gegen Schalke, jeweils 0 zu 3. Das tut schon weh und natürlich bleibt sowas irgendwie auch noch ein Stück mehr hängen bei der Breite der Fans, weil natürlich einfach 30.000, 40.000 im Stadion sind. Also, wenn du dann so ein 2-2 da irgendwie in Fürth auf dem Sonntag-Nametag hast, ist das vielleicht am Montag bei dem einen oder anderen auch wieder vergessen. Klammer auf, bei mir nicht. Aber diese beiden Auswärtsspiele, 2-2, kamen dann noch dazu. Und dann, okay, der Sieg gegen Bielefeld war dabei. Der hat das so ein bisschen aufgelockert, das Ganze. Aber wir haben ja, du hast es gerade schon angedeutet, wir haben beschlossen, welche Vereine wir reinnehmen und wie wir das Ganze machen, bevor der Spieltag gegen jetzt Braunschweig am Sonntag war. Und ich habe ganz klar gesagt, wenn wir das nicht gewinnen, dann könnte es sein, dass ich hier etwas polterhaft durch die Gegend erlichte. So ist es jetzt, dass ich schon sagen kann, wir haben uns wieder gefangen. Es ist alles erstmal ganz gut. Dieses wichtige Derby, was wir sehr, sehr lange nicht mehr gewonnen haben, zumindest nicht mehr mit Fans. Ich war mit vier Leuten unterwegs und ich glaube, ich war der Einzige, der einen Auswärts-Derby-Sieg in seinem Leben gesehen hat. Wir sind alle nicht 13 und 14, sondern– Krass! Wer es bei YouTube sieht, ist, wir sind in der Regel über 40 oder zumindest Ende 30. Das liegt daran, dass der letzte Sieg 2021 unter Corona-Bedingungen war. Da war gar keiner im Stadion. Der Sieg davor war dann Ende der 90er in der 3. Liga. Seitdem gab es keinen Auswärts-Sieg mehr. Es gab auch wirklich wenige Spiele, das muss man dazu sagen. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass das der ewig junge Schlager ist und man immer wieder gegeneinander spielt. Aber trotzdem, das zeigt schon, wie wichtig dieser Sieg war für viele Leute, die da im Stadion waren und teilweise auch einfach für Leute, die schon deutlich älter sind als 2021, 2022. Denn das war keine Selbstverständlichkeit am Sonntag.
Bevor wir da generell noch mehr in den Deep Dive gehen, eine ganz kurze Frage an Lisa. Hat dich das so ein bisschen überrascht zu sehen, dass Hannover da so ein bisschen nachgelassen hat?
Auf der einen Seite ja. Auf der anderen Seite, ehrlicherweise auch nicht. Tobi hatte das vorhin schon mal so ganz gut angerissen.
Es ist halt diese 2.
Liga. Und ich finde es so schwierig, sich da wirklich schon festzulegen. Also ich finde auch Tipps zum Beispiel immer ganz schlimm. Ich weiß noch, als wir hier tippen mussten vor der Saison. Deswegen habe ich immer das Gefühl, es hat eigentlich jeder mal so einen Ausreißer nach oben, aber dann auch mal so einen Ausreißer nach unten. Es gibt irgendwie kaum ein Team, das wirklich konstant mitspielt. Sei es dann einfach durch individuelle Fehler, sei es durch Verletzungen. Deswegen hat mich das ein bisschen überrascht in der Situation. Also gerade das härtere Spiel, ehrlicherweise. Aber andererseits auch wieder nicht, weil es dann doch wieder diese irre 2. Liga ist, die ich total liebe, die mich auch mal wahnsinnig macht. Und wo ich immer so denke, boah, wenn man keinen Verein in der 2. Liga hat, dann macht es eigentlich jeden Spieltag Bock, dazu zu gucken, weil halt immer mal wieder so eine Wundertüte drin steckt. Und ich finde, das ist jetzt so ein bisschen auch da an der ein oder anderen Stelle passiert. Deswegen war ich eher überrascht, dass es so, so gut am Anfang losging. Das war, glaube ich, auch nicht so ganz klar. Also habe ich auch noch gerade so ein bisschen rekapituliert vor der Folge. Wir hatten ja auch schon über Hannover mal gesprochen. Und auch, was bringt denn jetzt Christian Tietz jetzt mit? Und wie passt das zusammen? Ich fand auch den Kader ehrlicherweise super spannend. Da kann Tobi bestimmt auch an der ein oder anderen Stelle noch deutlich tiefer reingehen als ich, weil ich das total spannend fand. Welche Spieler sind da so gekommen? Aus welchen Ligen sind die? Ich kannte ehrlicherweise ungefähr niemanden, der da jetzt dazu kam. Und ich glaube, es ging nicht nur mir so. Nicht nur, weil ich jetzt nicht Hannover-Ultra bin, sondern ich glaube, ganz viele, die die 2. Liga verfolgen, weil sie halt einen Club in der 2. Liga haben, haben so ein Basic-Wissen über die anderen Teams oder kennen dann auch den ein oder anderen Spieler. Und ich muss echt sagen, Hannover war für mich ein bisschen so eine Black Box, wer da jetzt dazu gekommen ist und auch wie das läuft. Und ich finde es total spannend und auch ein Stück weit beneidenswert, wie gut das schon sich gefunden hat, ehrlicherweise, in Hannover. Aber gerne Tobi, als Experte, so ein bisschen dein Blick aufs Derby, aber auch auf Hannover generell, wie du es bewerten würdest vielleicht.
Fangen wir vielleicht mit dem Generellen mal an. Ja, mir ging das ähnlich wie dir, dass ich zumindest bei den meisten Spielern erstmal transfermarkt.de oder sonstige Seiten anschmeißen musste, um zu gucken, mit wem wir es denn da jetzt zu tun haben. Es hat sogar so weit geführt, dass ich eine Excel-Tabelle angeschmissen habe, wo ich so die Key-Facts mir eingetragen habe. Es waren glaube ich am Ende 17 oder 18 Spieler, die wir verpflichtet haben. Und trotz allem, oder am meisten hat mich dann eigentlich gewundert, dass wir trotzdem sehr weit oben von vielen gerankt wurden vor der Saison. Ich habe auch, ich glaube, wir haben ja diese Kacheln hier beim Rasenfunk rausgehauen. Da habe ich gesagt, komm, mache ich mit. Wenn man nicht dran glaubt, dann kann es ja auch nicht passieren. Wir werden schon aufsteigen. Aber eigentlich, also realistisch betrachtet, ein neuer Trainer, so viele neue Spieler, die komplette Achse. Wir müssen überlegen, letztes Jahr Ron-Robert Zieler im Tor, Halzenberg in der Innenverteidigung, Neumann abgegeben nach England. Das ist und vorne Trezoldi, jetzt hätte ich fast seinen Namen vergessen, um Gottes Willen. Also wir haben einfach auch wirklich einen großen, großen Cut im Kader gehabt und haben dafür Spieler geholt, die, wie gesagt, also klar, Neubauer von Elbersberg, das war natürlich ein Begriff, den haben wir dann ein Jahr davor da auf der linken Seite schon rumzaubern gesehen, oder auch die beiden Kieler mit Pichler und Sterner, auch die wusste man, aber wenn es dann irgendwie nach Südafrika geht oder nach Japan in die 2. Liga, sorry, bin ich echt raus, zumindest was so das vorherige Wissen angeht. Und dann hatten wir diese vier Spiele und sind in die Saison reingekommen und es klappte einfach alles. Also dieser Tits-Fußball war etwas, was ich glaube ich so diese ersten vier Spiele noch nie in Hannover gesehen habe. Vielleicht um den Bogen zurückzuschlagen, dass wir so wilden Fußball gespielt haben Ende der 90er, als wir dann von der 3. in die 2. Liga aufgestiegen sind. Aber da waren wir einfach, da hatten wir so einen Unfall von sich gerade.
Gott, ich hatte so Angst, was du jetzt sagst. Ich habe mir Kusslomka schon in meinem Kopf mache.
Ja, das war sicherlich auch ein ganz besonderer Fußball. Also die erste Zeit mit Slomka, das war schon wild und auch gut in Europa. Da hatten wir schon Spaß. Aber dass wir wirklich, dass wir so was Besonderes hatten, wo man sich glaube ich auch lange daran erinnern kann. Ich habe es vergessen, wir haben ja mit Fronsek und Kenan Kutschak und wie sie alle heißen, haben wir uns hier trainieren lassen. Und Thomas Doil, also, Gott des Willen.
Das vergesse ich immer.
Ja, und Thomas Doil, hätte ich auch gar nicht mehr.
Das ist noch nicht das Schlimmste, Gott sei Dank vergesse ich auch viel. Und das ist auch gar nicht so schlecht. Deshalb waren diese ersten vier Spieltage, es war, ohne Scheiß, es war ein Rausch. Ich dachte, wie es ist, es war ein kompletter Rausch. Das sah spannend aus, das war toll. Der Trainer hat sich mit 9 Torwart gewünscht. Der hat die Ziele auch ein Stück weit verdrängt. Oder Ziele ist freiwillig gegangen. Oder Köln war attraktiver. Ich habe keine Ahnung, es ist egal, wie man das am Ende formuliert. Auf jeden Fall hatten wir 0 auf einmal im Tor stehen. Und der ist dann der fünfte oder sechste Innenverteidiger, weil der Vogelwild durch die Gegend läuft, aber eine Ballbehandlung hat. Da kann sich der ein oder andere Stürmer und Mittelfeldspieler sicherlich noch eine Scheibe von abschneiden. Und dann haben wir einfach einen komplett anderen Fußball gesehen. Es wird nicht mehr nach vorne gebolzt oder Abschläge gemacht. Es wird alles spielerisch von hinten aufgebaut. Und wenn der Gegner mit 9 Spielern auf unsere Abwehrreihe zu presst, dann wird immer noch nicht gebolzt. Dann wird trotzdem versucht, das spielerisch zu lösen. Dann kommen wir wieder zum Alter. Ich bin in einem Alter, das vertrage ich nicht so gut. Also das ist wirklich...
Da trägt man in keinem Alter.
Es ist der... Also das sind alles Sachen, die haben mich... Ich war darauf nicht vorbereitet, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Es war die letzten Jahre anders. Und es ist jetzt einfach, dass diese Innenverteidiger und Enzo Leopold rückt meistens noch ein Stück zurück, um den Ball entgegenzunehmen und das Spiel wieder aufzubauen. Dass die eine Ballsicherheit haben, zumindest meistens, die mich erfreut, aber auch mich auch ein bisschen erschreckt. Wenn es da nicht klappt, dann kommen wir in Probleme, ist klar. Haben wir glaube ich auch schon ein, zwei Gegentore gefressen. Es ist ein Risiko, dass es immer mit dabei ist. Jetzt geht das ganz bewusst ein. Auch Gott sei Dank. Ich hoffe, dass die Spieler nicht das Selbstvertrauen verlieren, wenn sie Fehler machen. Ich hoffe, dass sie in der Mannschaft gestärkt werden, dass sie als Kollektiv sagen, wir wollen das so spielen, wir sind davon überzeugt, das ist okay. Du darfst dann auch mal einen Fehler machen, weil wenn du einen Fehler machst, ist das Ding in der Regel durch. Also dann stehen die Gegner mit zwei Leuten vor dem Tor und dann ist das Tor da. Ich fluche da ab und zu drüber. Ich fluche da auch teilweise sehr laut drüber, aber es ist schon sehr beeindruckend und macht super viel Spaß, das Ganze zu sehen. Und auch wenn es zwischendurch mal ein bisschen geruppelt hat, Gott sei Dank im Derby dann auch dazu geführt, dass alles gut war und dass das funktioniert hat.
Ja, dann lass uns einmal ganz kurz einen Blick auf dieses Derby werfen. Am Ende war es eben ein 3 zu 0-Sieg gegen Eintracht Braunschalk. Du hast es eben schon gesagt. Ich würde aber schon sagen, begünstigt durch den frühen Platzverweis von Yadimchi. Generell Platzverweise bei Eintracht Braunschalk ein Problem. Da könnt ihr nochmal reinhören, was Anna dazu sagt. Ich glaube, es ist die fünfte rote Karte in zehn Spielen. Es ist sehr interessant, dass Yadimchi sich heute, glaube ich, entschuldigt hat generell bei seinen Mitspielern, bei seinem Trainerteam und bei seinen Fans. Bei Tomiak hat er sich nie entschuldigt.
Also, wir sind uns doch einig, dass Tomiak ihm irgendeine Geschichte auf dem Platz erzählt hat, oder? Also, es gab vor so ein Kopfball-Duell, da hatte Tomiak nach einer Ecke ein Kopfball-Duell gewonnen gegen ihn. Vielleicht hat er ihm da schon ein bisschen Trash-Talk ins Ohr genuschelt. Aber so reagierst du doch nicht, wenn alles ein normales Fußballspiel ist. Da muss der Derby hin oder her so...
Selbst für einen Derby war das krass, ja.
Vor allem, also, ehrlich gesagt, ich sage das an der Stelle auch nochmal, Tätlichkeiten in Zeiten von VHR sind für mich das Dürmste, was du machen kannst. Also klar, Tomiak macht da auch relativ viel raus. Also, ich möchte nicht bezweifeln, dass so ein Griff an die Kehle nicht angenehm ist, aber er macht da gut, brauchen wir nicht weiter diskutieren.
Kann ich ganz kurz zurückfragen zu dem Thema? Weil im Stadion konnte ich es gar nicht sehen. Im Stadion sah es so aus, als wenn er ihm so an der Brust rumfummelt. Das war aber offensichtlich nicht der Fall. Dann habe ich die Wiederholung gesehen, da konnte man sogar so ein bisschen sehen, dass da so auf der roten Haut so Fingerabdrücke zu sehen waren am Hals. Okay, aber Tomiak stand doch die ganze Zeit und dann auf einmal lager.
Ja, genau.
So eine Luft, die verschwand nach 30 Sekunden. Das habe ich nicht ganz verstanden.
Ja, genau. Also wahrscheinlich um drauf aufmerksam machen, um das so ein bisschen dem Schiedsrichter auch nochmal zur Kenntnis zu machen. Hallo, hier ist was passiert. Gut, da brauchen wir nicht weiter zu diskutieren. Also, das klingt jetzt ein bisschen doof. Ich wäre sehr gespannt gewesen, wie dieses Spiel weitergelaufen wäre. Hätte man das 11 gegen 11 zu Ende gespielt? Ich würde davon, also man muss ja trotzdem sagen, Hannover hat sich schon nicht schwer getan, aber das Tor zu treffen war doch erst so ein kleines Problem. Da wäre ich schon mal gespannt gewesen, wie es gelaufen wäre, wenn da halt Gleichzahl auf dem Platz gestanden hätte. Aber trotzdem muss man sagen, die Fehler, die Braunschweig gemacht haben, ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass das mit einem Mann mehr nicht dazu geführt hat, weil einfach die Basics an Fehlern zu machen, Hannover da laufen zu lassen, Hannover kommen zu lassen, das war halt einfach nicht besonders clever. Again, ich verweise euch da gerne auf Annas Aussagen, zuletzt die, glaube ich, sowieso nicht generell. Heiner Backhaus, großer Fan ist an der Stelle. Man muss, glaube ich, sagen, einfach nachdem man eben diese Spiele gegen Fürth und gegen Dresden hatte, mit zwei Teams, die weiter unten stehen, eben jetzt gegen Braunschweig, dann doch noch mal gegen einen– ja, es ist nicht respektlos gemeint– aber in allen Formen des Kaders, eigentlich schwächeren Teams, eben doch das relativ deutlich zu machen, nach dieser 0-3-Niederlage gegen Schalke. Ich glaube, das war ein sehr, sehr wichtiger Sieg, einfach in der Gesamtkonstellation.
Absolut. Und ich teile dein Interesse– also, das teile ich persönlich nicht, aber ich weiß, dass es ein anderes Spiel gewesen wäre, wenn diese rote Karte nicht gekommen wäre. Wie gesagt, ich wäre nicht daran interessiert gewesen, das zu erfahren, aber ich stelle es mir durchaus auch vor, dass das schwieriger geworden wäre für 96 gegen dann Elfmann, beziehungsweise es gab ja auch die andere Alternative, und da müssen wir jetzt mal ganz klar Christian Titz loben, der verhindert hat, dass es 10 gegen 10 ist. Also Bundu hatte schon eine gelbe Karte, hatte dann eine Szene, die ja, so la la. Also ich hatte das Gefühl, der Schiri hat ihm noch die allerletzte Chance gegeben. Und dann als Trainer in der 45. Minute, also vor der Halbzeit, zu sagen, ich nehme dich raus. Alle wussten, es gibt so ein paar Minuten Nachspielzeit, wegen Unterbrechung, wegen kleines Feuerchen. Ist natürlich, grundsätzlich gibt es immer die Aussage, das ist die Höchststrafe, wenn du in der ersten Halbzeit ausgewechselt wirst, genauso wie wenn du eingewechselt und dann wieder ausgewechselt wirst. Aber in dem Fall war es einfach, das war Christian Titz Masterclass. Das war genau der richtige Moment, ich glaube, Bundu hätte keine Sekunde länger spielen dürfen. Neben dem Trainer haben zwei Leute, die in dieser Szene in meinen Augen sehr gut reagiert haben. Das eine war Enzo Leopold, der Kapitän, der sofort zu Bundu hingegangen ist, als es hieß, du musst runter. Der ihm was auch immer gesagt hat, aber zumindest ihm gezeigt hat, dass es richtig war, du hast ein gutes Spiel gemacht. Er hatte ja das Tor vorbereitet, zum 1-0 war das. Genau das war das 1-0, was er vorbereitet hatte. Der zweite war Virgil Gieta, unser Innenverteidiger, der sich umgedreht hat und dann Richtung Gäste block, die gerade irgendwas gesungen haben, angezeigt hat, dass sie applaudieren sollen für Bundu. Das war so eine Szene, die mich sehr glücklich gestimmt hat und gezeigt hat, die Mannschaft, die denken mit, die haben ein bisschen Fingerspitzengefühl, die wissen, was man in solchen Situationen machen muss, damit Bundu jetzt nicht denkt, oh Scheiße, ich werde ausgewechselt in der ersten Halbzeit, ich werde irgendwie bestraft oder so. Das Ganze mit Titz und Bundu noch hinterher, als er dann rausgenommen hat, haben sie noch kurz gesprochen. Es sah sehr harmonisch aus, das Ganze. Das war einer der vielen Punkte, die mir an dem Tag sehr gut gefallen haben.
Generell, wir kommen gleich noch darauf zu sprechen, warum dieses Derby in vielerlei Hinsicht ein besonderes war. Aber ich bin jetzt tatsächlich sehr gespannt, denn man hat ein durchaus interessantes Programm vor sich. Auswärts bei der SVE, zu Hause gegen Darmstadt oder auswärts bei Paderborn. Ich sage mal so, ich habe eben bei Bielefeld gesagt, ich hoffe, wir sehen ein anderes Gesicht. Ich würde mal sagen, du würdest das unterschreiten, wenn ich sage, du möchtest auch ein anderes Gesicht gegen diese 3 Vereine als das, was man gegen Schalke gezeigt hat.
Also Elvesberg, finde ich, kann nach 4 Siegen, können sie jetzt ja auch 4 mal verlieren. Also Bielefeld legt vor und wir machen nach, wäre ich voll und ganz fein. Aber grundsätzlich hast du natürlich recht, das ist ein Brett. Und genau deshalb war es ja auch mega, mega wichtig, jetzt diese drei Punkte mitzunehmen. Weil also Gesamtsituation wäre hoch problematisch gewesen, wenn wir nicht gewonnen hätten und wenn wir verloren hätten, brauchen wir gar nicht drüber zu reden. Da gab es dann Trainer, die auf dem Zaun standen mit Megafon und versucht haben, die Menge zu beruhigen. Also da war ich Christian Titz nicht, nicht, dass ich ihm das nicht zutraue, aber das wäre halt etwas, oh Gott, das wäre wirklich fürchterlich gewesen. Und jetzt, ja, jetzt hat man gezeigt, dass man diesen Charakter hat, dieses Derby zu gewinnen. Das ist sehr gut gewesen. Und jetzt muss man halt auch zeigen, dass man in der Tabelle Vereine, die oben stehen, Eversberg, steht noch vor uns. Ich blicke ein bisschen runter. Darmstadt ist zwei Punkte hinter uns. Paderborn ist drei Punkte vor uns. Und Karlsruhe ist wiederum zwei Punkte hinter uns. Also das ist eigentlich alles, das ist unsere Kategorie. Und jetzt sind das vier Spiele. Wenn man danach weiterhin vierter ist, dann hat man nicht viel falsch gemacht. Ich denke, das sollte das Ziel sein. Ob das klappt, wird man sehen. Wie das so mit dem Ball im Strafraum und den kurzen Pässen und dem mutigen Spielaufbau, in welche Richtung sich das so entwickelt.
Eine letzte Frage habe ich noch, bevor wir dann auf Daniela Behrens zu sprechen kommen. Also beziehungsweise von außen habe ich das Gefühl, dass die Beziehung zwischen Verein und Mannschaft und Fans unverein, ehrlich gesagt, so gut ist wie lange nicht mehr. Also das Stadion ist voll, gut auswärts hatte man glaube ich immer einen ganz guten Mob dabei, aber man hat irgendwie generell das Gefühl, die Laune ist ganz gut, vielleicht die Toleranzschwelle auch einfach ein bisschen höher gesetzt in dem Sinne, dass man vielleicht der Mannschaft ein bisschen mehr Zeit gibt, als wäre das jetzt eben noch letztes Jahr unter Leitl gewesen. Würdest du mir das zustimmen? Würdest du mir das zustimmen oder ist das ein Trugschluss von außen?
Nee, glaube ich schon. Ich glaube, das stimmt ein Stück weit. Neben dieser ganzen sportlichen Sache, wo man ja erstmal der Mannschaft Zeit geben sollte und das Gefühl habe ich auch, wird ihr gegeben. Die vollen Stadien, weiß nicht, ob es immer nur an den Heimfans gelegen hat. Also klar, die Nordkurve, der harte Kern, der ist immer da, gar keine Frage. Dann gibt es auf der Westtribüne auch einen Bereich, der immer gut bis sehr gut verkauft ist. Aber dass dann am Ende eine Zahl ist, die größer ist als 45.000, das geht in der Regel in Hannover, zumindest in der 2. Liga nicht ohne den Gastverein. Bielefeld war da, Schalke, ich meine, guck, wer da war, das ist ja, Lautern war da, Magdeburg ist auch nicht so weit weg von Hannover, Hertha war da. Also das sind alles Vereine, die dann auch ordentlich mitbringen und am Ende dafür sorgen, dass die Zahl, ich glaube, wir haben jetzt einen Schnitt von 47.000 oder so. Das ist Wahnsinn. Also klar, der sportliche Erfolg tut dann auch so ein bisschen seinen Teil dazu. Wir haben diese Geschichte, ich weiß nicht, inwieweit das mitbekommen wurde. Die Sitze sollen verändert werden im nächsten Jahr. Die Farbe der Sitze, das war ja immer noch dieses alte, hässliche Blau, was eigentlich gar nichts mit Hannover 96 zu tun hat, aber die gab es, soweit ich gehört habe, mal recht kostengünstig im Einkauf, als das Stadion gebaut wurde. Jetzt hat man gesagt, man möchte gerne investieren und möchte gerne auch, dass das Stadion so aussieht, wie es aussehen soll. Da gab es eine Abstimmung, da hat man die Fans mitgenommen, hat nicht einfach was entschieden, sondern hat gefragt, hier sind 5 Vorschläge. Ich meine, am Ende, ich weiß bis heute nicht mehr, was die Unterschiede waren, wo jetzt oben, unten, egal. Aber auch das macht einen guten Eindruck und man darf es wahrscheinlich wirklich nicht unterschlagen. Martin Kind, der für viele das Problem bei Hannover 96 ist, hatte sich längererfristig aus der Öffentlichkeit zurückgezogen, so wie ich jetzt gehört habe, aus gesundheitlichen Gründen. Und ich habe das Gefühl, wenn Martin Kind nicht viel gefragt wird, bzw. nicht oft irgendwelche Zitate von ihm in der Zeitung stehen, egal wie viel Fundament die vielleicht haben oder wie sinnig die auch sein mögen, es ist völlig egal. Die Leute regen sich einfach weniger auf, wenn man weniger von ihm liest, wenn man Hannover 96. Das ist einfach so. Egal, welche Seite. Wenn er was sagt, was irgendwem nicht gefällt und irgendwem doch, dann regen sich zumindest eine Hälfte, und dann regen sich die eine Hälfte über die andere Hälfte. Es ist einfach, und ich mache das hier sehr lange, es ist einfach so ein leidiges Thema. Deshalb war es tatsächlich so seit Sommer ganz chillig und nett.
Wie sehr froh bist du, dass du ausnahmsweise mal nicht wieder die gesellschaftliche oder gesellschaftliche Organisation von Hannover 96 hier aussehen musstest. Ich habe sie immer griffbereit. Ich gehe davon aus sehr froh. Ich bin es auf jeden Fall, weil jedes Mal, wenn ich versuche, mir das durchzulesen und zu verstehen, dass diese Nampsen in meinem Gehirn keine Gruppe haben.
Es wird die Zeit kommen, wo das wieder ein Thema wird, wenn es um 50 plus 1 und eine halbe Stunde um 50 plus 1 geht. Gar keine Frage, dann wird auch Hannover wieder ganz vorne in der Geschichte diskutiert werden. Aber aktuell ist es ja auch so ein Thema, wo die meisten sich einfach auch ungern zu rühren, also allen voran von denen, die was zu entscheiden haben. Im Moment ist es so, wie es ist. Ich bin mit der Gesamtsituation zufrieden.
Lisa, Entschuldige bitte, aber wir haben noch ein letztes Thema, und das ist die Stadion-Auslastung bei Derbys. Tobi, ich würde einfach mal ganz grob anfangen, und du fängst mich bitte ein bzw. korrigierst mich. Also, es gab ja zuletzt mehrere Male Derbys, eigentlich vor allem ohne organisierte Fanszenen, sowohl heim- als auch auswärts, um Gottes willen. Also zum Teil waren natürlich trotzdem Fans im Stadion. Ich rede jetzt explizit von organisierten Fanszenen, weil sie eben ja nicht mitgehen wollten, was Daniela Behrens als Innenminister von Niedersachsen da so wollte. Das war jetzt ein Konzept auf Bewährung, deshalb gab es eigentlich eine nahezu voll besetzte Stadion. Es gab eine große, also du kannst es gerne gleich näher deine Eindrücke aus dem Stadion beschreiben, es gab eben alle möglichen Vorrichtungen, um da, ich glaube Bälle auf dem Rasen etc., irgendwelches Aufeinanderprallen von gegnerischen Fanszenen zu verhindern. Genau, jetzt war eben der Gästeblog ausverkauft. Es gab ein geschärftes Sicherheitskonzept für das Spiel, die Einlasskontrollen sollten noch strenger sein, es gab mehr Ordner und das Einzige, was es nicht gab, war ein streng personalisiertes Ticket zu Gästefans, die wurde, also das war eine Forderung der Polizei und da haben aber beide Clubs gesagt, nee, das wollen wir nicht. So, jetzt, das ist der grobe Rahmen. Magst du vielleicht einmal sagen, was ist denn überhaupt der Standpunkt der Vereine, der Fans und was ist denn das Problem von Daniela Behrens? Vorsichtig aus. Ich glaube, das wird zu…
Fangen wir einfach hinten an. Daniela Behrens hatte sich, nachdem, jetzt muss ich kurz überlegen, das muss 2024, also nicht in der letzten Saison, da war ohne Zuschauer, sondern davor. Es gab ja noch weiter davor, gab es ja mal diese Situation, dass im Gästeblog, also wo Hannover drin war, Rauchbomben, der Heimmannschaft gezündet wurden, dann gab es im Rückspiel natürlich die Angst der Gäste, dass das auch der Fall ist, dann haben sie da die halbe Sitzbänke auseinandergebaut. Also es schaukelte sich mit fragwürdigen Aktionen ein bisschen hoch und gipfelte dann, meiner Meinung nach, in dem Auswärtsspiel von Hannover in Braunschweig, wo vor dem Gästeblog, ich glaube, dass es tatsächlich auch nichts Ungewöhnliches ist, dass der Gästeblog so ein bisschen so eingezäunt ist mit so einem Netz. Das gibt es teilweise sogar über die ganze Hintertortribüne in einem oder anderen Stadion. Und da war es jetzt natürlich um den Gästeblog, wo Hannover drin war. Da, also muss man ganz klar sagen, da wurden Grenzen überschritten von der 96 Auswärtsfans. Da wurde das Netz herangezogen. Da wurden durch das Netz Raketen in den Heimbereich geschossen auf Menschen, die da saßen. Egal, wo die jetzt herkamen, ob das Braunschweiger, Kieler oder Menschen mit Kindern. Scheißegal, man schießt nicht mit Raketen auf Menschenpunkt. Das war eine Grenze, die überschritten war. Das andere war, weil es von der Außenwirkung ein Komplettes Desaster ist, wenn du 500 Sitze anzündest. Das sieht auch nicht gut aus, wenn wirklich so 2-3 Meter hohe... Das ist Käse, das hat man gemacht. Das hat Frau Behrens, die Innenministerin, die früher noch, glaube ich, die Gesundheitsministerin oder so, was in Niedersachsen war, hat das auf den Plan gerufen und sie wollte das nutzen, um, also ich gehe mal davon aus, sich ein bisschen ins Gespräch zu bringen, ihr Profil zu schärfen, hat gesagt, da müssen wir hart durchgreifen, ihr könnt euch das vorstellen, wie das alles so ist. Die Suche ist nicht von der Partei, die ihr jetzt gerade denkt, sondern ist tatsächlich von der SPD, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Und die wollte da hart durchgreifen und hat gesagt, das geht so nicht, wir müssen Gäste-Fans ausschließen, wir müssen, wir müssen, wir müssen. Und dann ging es in der letzten Saison darum, dass maximal die Hälfte oder ich glaube 60 Prozent, also auf jeden Fall nicht die volle Auslastung im Gästeblog ist. Und da kommen wir dann zu dem Thema, was wollen die Fans, die wollen natürlich einen vollen Gästeblog. Da sind sich beide Seiten auch einig. Die Regel war nun, es gibt nur einen gewissen Anteil. Dementsprechend hat erst Braunschweig in Hannover gesagt, wir kommen nicht und dann war es andersrum. Ich kriege es auch gar nicht mehr zusammen. Wir waren erst auswärts nicht da und dann waren die bei uns nicht da. Wie gesagt, alles auf die organisierte Fanszene bezogen. So ein paar Leute waren natürlich trotzdem da. Man konnte tatsächlich mal einfach Karten kriegen fürs Derby. Das heißt, die Fans wollen natürlich volle Auslastung in den Blöcken. Jetzt ging es auf unser Spiel am letzten Wochenende zu. Frau Behrens hatte vorher groß angekündigt, dass das wieder so wird wie letztes Jahr. Dann wurde es ein bisschen ruhiger in der ganzen Geschichte und man hörte lange nichts. Klar, wir wissen alle, da wird im Hintergrund viel diskutiert und gemacht und getan. Dann gab es, das muss ich lügen, 2 Monate oder 1,5 Monate vor dem Spiel, äußerte sich Eintracht Braunschweig als Verein und hat gesagt, man hat uns gebeten, wir sollen personalisierte Tickets machen und das können wir nicht. Das können wir nicht und das wollen wir nicht. Es ist einfach nicht machbar, den Gästeblock mit personalisierten Tickets. Der Einlass, da passen 2.000, 2.500 Leute rein. Wenn du die personalisiert kontrollierst, der Tag ist vorbei, es funktioniert einfach nicht. Ich weiß nicht, was alles im Hintergrund passiert ist. Es ist sicherlich viel passiert. Man hat miteinander gesprochen und Ende vom Lead war tatsächlich Vollauslastung für den Gästeblock, das heißt, das, was die Fans haben wollten. Und das, was die Innenministerin haben wollte, hat man ihr wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen gegeben mit einem verschärften, erhöhten Sicherheitskonzept. Eine andere Einlasssituation, die ich tatsächlich als sehr positiv wahrgenommen habe. Ich habe so gut wie nie Schlangen gesehen, sonst gab es immer, das ist so ein, ich weiß nicht, wenn ihr in Braunschweig im Gästeblock schon mal wartet, das ist so ein ganz, ganz abgetrennter Bereich mit so Drehkreuzen und alles ist vergittert. Also es ist wirklich nicht schön.
Drehkreuze sind sowieso raus aus Fußballstadien. Das möchte ich an der Stelle noch mal ganz klar sagen, vor allem das in Braunschweig, weil das nicht funktioniert, dass du quasi dein Ticket vorhältst und dann durchgehst, sondern dass es ein sich quasi von Fans selber gedrehtes Drehkreuz, was einfach dazu führen soll, bevor du dein Ticket kontrolliert wirst, dass die Leute nicht einfach durchgehen. Und die Dinger drehen sich so schnell und ich finde es brutal gefährlich, das nur als kleiner Einwand, weil wir selber im Braunschweig gerade vor einem Monat oder so gespielt haben. Ich finde es eine kaputte Kastrophe.
Einfach nicht gut, ja absolut. Bin ich vorhin ganz bei dir. Es gab jetzt neben diesem Einlasskonzert, die meisten Fans sind mit einem Sonderzug rübergefahren, der tatsächlich so lang war. Ich habe noch nie so einen langen Regionalexpress in Hannover gesehen. Da haben sie einfach zwei hintereinander gehängt und haben quasi alle oder fast alle Fans, die mit Öffis anreisen wollten, dahin gebracht. Dann ist es im Braunschweig so, dass du immer durch den alten Posttunnel hinten rausgehst. Da sammelt man sich dann und dann kommt ein Bus nach dem nächsten. Ich hätte gesagt, das waren so vielleicht 25, 30 Busse. Man mag mich gerne kontrollieren. Die dann relativ zügig die Fans zum Stadion gebracht haben. Auch das ist im Braunschweig nicht so. Man fährt vom Bahnhof zum Stadion, sondern man fährt gefühlt fast wieder zurück nach Hannover, damit man halt nicht da langfährt, wo die Heimfans anreisen. Alles okay. Am Ende kommt alle in den Gästebereich. Der Gästebereich war auch relativ früh sehr gut gefüllt. Da kann man nichts gegen sagen. Im Bereich selber war, glaube ich, die größte Veränderung im Vergleich zum vorherigen Spiel, dass nicht ein Netz, sondern zwei Netze hingen. Also wenn man ein Netz ranzieht und ein Loch reinbrennt oder schneidet, dann reicht das noch nicht. Das Netz davor war so drei, vier Meter weiter vorne. Man kam nicht wirklich ran. Am Anfang gab es noch so ein bisschen Turmulte zwischen Ordnern und so, aber es regelte sich dann und bis zum Ende passierte auch nichts. Es flog nichts aus dem Block. Es brannte nichts auf dem Rasen. Vielleicht brannte es ganz kurz mal. Ihr habt ja gesehen, Pyrotechnik gab es natürlich reichlich und es wird, wenn Frau Behrens schlechte Laune hat, auch dafür reichen, dass sie Gründe findet, von Randale und Ausschreitungen zu sprechen für jemanden, der da sicherlich eine andere Grenze legt, bei was Probleme angeht. Ich habe es vorhin gesagt, was meines Erachtens nicht in Ordnung ist. Ich fand, das war, ja, 5 Minuten Spielunterbrechung müssen auch nicht zwingend sein, aber das ist halt, sollen sie besser einen Rauchabzug einbauen, dann passiert das auch nicht. Also grundsätzlich war das, finde ich, das, was ich bei einem Derby erwarte und so, wie ich mir das vorstelle und das war von daher völlig in Ordnung. Braunschweig selber hatte gar nichts gemacht. Ich glaube, da gab es technische Probleme. Das sollte ja ein Problem sein. Also Hannover wirklich mit einem schönen, soliden Auftritt, ein bisschen Pyro, schön ein bisschen Fahnen, gute Stimmung gewonnen, alles war herrlich. Und ich würde jetzt sagen, ohne dass ich weder bei der Polizei noch beim Innenministerium bin, für mich hat das Konzept funktioniert. Es sind alle heile nach Hause gekommen, hoffe ich zumindest, habe nichts Gegenteiliges gehört. Und es hat, also ich will es vielleicht nicht zu hoch hängen, aber insgesamt hat es das Ganze irgendwie noch mal so ein bisschen, also dieser Tag auf ein vernünftiges Niveau gebracht. Also ja, da werden Sachen gerufen, da können wir lange darüber diskutieren. Muss man nicht, man muss den Gegner nicht als das bezeichnen, was da bezeichnet wurde. Man muss nicht den Tod wünschen und so weiter. Kann aber jeder machen, wie er möchte. Möchte ich mich jetzt hier nicht aufspielen. Ich fand es trotzdem gut, der Stadionssprecher von Braunschweig war gestorben. Hannover hat, als das thematisiert wurde und da nochmal eine Ansprache gab, hat Hannover sich vernünftig benommen. Als Hannover Gästeblog ein Arzteinsatz war und Ruhe war, hatte Braunschweig sich dem angeschlossen. Also, ich sage mal so, die guten Sitten des Fußballs wurden eingehalten und es hat auf beiden Seiten trotzdem, fand ich, vernünftige Stimmung, also von Hannover natürlich logischerweise, bessere Stimmung gegeben, sodass ich sagen kann, das, oder aus meinem Empfinden, war das eine rundum gelungene Sache, die, ja, so kann es gerne bleiben. Also, wir müssen nicht dann irgendwann wieder Bänke ausschrauben und Sitze anzünden und so. Das können wir uns gerne sparen. Lass uns beleidigen, alles gut. Aber vielleicht ohne diese ganz große Schraube.
Ja, als letzten Punkt vielleicht noch, gerade im Bezug auf das Rückspiel. Die Fan-Hilfe Hannover hat da, glaube ich, auch nochmal Punkte aufgelistet und es geht vor allem auch eben, glaube ich, um das Thema Mitbestimmung bzw. mit einem Tisch sitzen, wenn es eben um dieses Thema Sicherheit in den Stadien geht. Es gab ja in der Vergangenheit eben mit den mehreren niedersächsischen Clubs, also Hannover, Braunschweig, Wolfsburg und Osnabrück, eigentlich diese Treffen und da hat Osnabrück unter anderem einmal abgesagt, weil eben die angekündigten Teilnehmer aus der Fanszene eben nicht mit am Tisch sitzen sollten. Und also das ist sowieso ein bekanntes Problem, dass die Problematik sehen wir jetzt auch wieder bei dieser Innenministerkonferenz, dass eben ja Fan-Vertreterinnen da immer wieder ausgeschlossen werden. Und ich glaube, wir können uns generell darauf einigen, dass es mehr Sinn ergibt, mit Fan-Vertretern zu sprechen als über sie, weil dann ist es– also man hat ja zum Beispiel jetzt gesehen, wenn zum Beispiel Clubs mit zusammenarbeiten und klar sagen so, hey, wir sind ja auch fein mit einem Sicherheitskonzept, was ein bisschen nerviger oder ein bisschen strenger geht. Und vielleicht ist es in manchen Sachen sogar sinnvoller, weil es auch einfach um Unsicherheit, in einer Einlasssituation geht etc. Aber nehmt uns doch mit an den Tisch und dann ist es einfacher. Aber also ich glaube, dafür muss man einfach sagen und ohne Daniela Behrens da zu nahe treten zu wollen. Aber ich habe manchmal auch das Gefühl, da besteht überhaupt kein Interesse, da wirklich ein Dialog führen zu wollen, sondern Tobi, ich glaube, du hast es eben immer so nett gesagt, so ihr Profil zu schärfen.
Ja, also man hat ja tatsächlich auch von ihr nichts mehr gehört, als es darum ging, es ist ein voller Stadion oder volle Auslastung. Das hat dann die Polizei Braunschweig kommuniziert. Also natürlich gibt es da auch Verbindung, gar keine Frage, logisch. Aber da war es dann relativ ruhig um sie. Also es ist relativ deutlich, in welche Richtung sie da möchte. Und natürlich hast du auch vollkommen recht, es wird ein Verein, wenn da Martin Kind oder wer auch immer in diesem Treffen sitzt, der wird nicht wissen, wie sich das Drehkreuz im Gästeblock anfühlt. Also der weiß, wie unangenehm es ist, wenn man mit einem H- oder irgendwas Kennzeichen nach Braunschweig fährt. Dass da keiner vielleicht was zu sagen, oder dass das die Häppchen im VIP-Block nicht so gut schmängelt. Ich glaube, der fährt da gar nicht mehr hin. Aber natürlich müssen da auch Leute sitzen, die das Ganze vor Ort kennen und ja miterlebt haben.
Gut, ich würde an der Punkt sagen, wir sind ein bisschen über meine Zeit, die ich haben wollte. Wir hatten aber auch ein, zwei technische Probleme, die ihr hoffentlich nicht so mitbekommen habt. Von daher vielen Dank an der Stelle erst mal für eure Geduld. Ich habe aber noch ein bisschen Hauskeepers zu tun, bevor ich euch verabschiede. Als erstes der Hinweis. Die nächste Sendung, die kommt dann mit Marc am 9. November. Und dann ist wieder Länderspielpause. Ihr habt es hier vielleicht jetzt schon mitbekommen. Wir hatten einmal die Ausnahme, dass wir eben trotzdem eine Länderspielpause aufgenommen haben. Wir wollen jetzt aber wirklich immer schauen, dass wir eben die zwei Spieltage vorbei haben, weil ein Spiel zu besprechen, das ergibt einfach nicht so wahnsinnig viel Sinn. Deshalb kommt dann die nächste Folge voraussichtlich erst am 1.12. Und das liegt daran, dass mein eigener Verein dann an dem Sonntagderby gegen Münster spielt und zur Verschonung aller möchte niemand, dass ich an dem gleichen Abend noch einen Podcast aufnehme. So viel sei schon mal gesagt. Sonst wisst ihr es alle, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich ausschließlich durch eure Gelder, das ihr eben spendet. Das könnt ihr auf diverse Wege tun. Mehr Infos gibt es da auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub, wenn ihr eben supporter werden wollt. Die Infos findet ihr in den Shownotes. Und der Dank geht stellvertretend heute an Dennis J., Susanne, Nico Rublik, Philipp und Schumi. Vielen Dank, dass ihr bereits den Rasenfunk unterstützt und nicht nur ermöglicht, dass Marc und ich hier sitzen, sondern eben unsere Gästinnen auch entlohnt werden. Zu den Sendungen, die es in dieser Woche gibt oder gegeben hat. Heute ist bereits die Sendung zur Bundesliga der Männer erschienen. Dann gibt es eine Sendung zum Länderspiel der Frauen. Morgen Abend gibt es ja das Rückspiel gegen Frankreich in der Nations League nach dem 1-0-Sieg am Freitag. Darauf könnt ihr euch auch freuen. Es erfolgt eventuell noch ein Teamschwerpunkt im Laufe der Woche. Mal schauen, wer sich da anbietet. Sonst würde ich jetzt tatsächlich sagen, vielen, vielen lieben Dank an meine beiden Gäste. Zum einen Tobi Rieger, danke, dass du mal wieder im Rasenfunk dabei warst.
Sehr gerne. Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Und vielen Dank auch an Lisa Höfer, dass du dich in ganzem Stress auch Zeit für uns genommen hast. Danke.
Immer sehr, sehr gerne. Und vielen, vielen Dank dir, Eva, dass du dich hier trotz Erkältung durch die Folge gekämpft hast und so gut durchgehalten hast. Also Props und bis ganz bald hoffentlich.
Dann sage ich nur Danke an euch und Tschüss.
Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir freuen uns über ihre Unterstützung.
Lernst ab, ist die Geschichte und dann werden sie sehen, Herr Reporter, wie sich das damals im Parlament entwickelt hat.